FIVE"
FIVE."
SEVERAL MAJOR STORIES WE ARE
COVERING TONIGHT, JOE BIDEN HAS
BEEN HECKLED ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL AND WHAT HE'S NOW SAYING
ABOUT TESTIFYING IN THE SENATE
IMPEACHMENT TRIAL.
TOUGH LIBERAL CITIES BLAME
PRESIDENT TRUMP OVER THE GROWING
HOMELESS CRISIS.
BUT FIRST, A GOOD GUY WITH THE
GUN IS BEING PRAISED FOR
PREVENTING A MASSACRE IN TEXAS.
JUST SECONDS AFTER HE OPENS FIRE
IN THE CHURCH KILLING TWO
PEOPLE.
LOCAL OFFICIALS IN THE PAST ARE
SAYING MAN SAVED COUNTLESS QUIET
LIVES.
>> WE CAN'T PREVENT MENTAL
ILLNESS AND WE CAN'T PREVENT
EVERY CRAZY PERSON FROM PULLING
A GUN.
THIS CHURCH AS A MODEL FOR THAT
PREPARATION.
>> WE LOST TWO GREAT MEN TODAY.
BUT IT COULD HAVE BEEN A LOT
WORSE.
AND I'M THANKFUL THAT OUR
GOVERNMENT HAS ALLOWED US THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT
OURSELVES.
>> THE MAN THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT IS NOW SPEAKING OUT AFTER
SPRINGING INTO ACTION.
>> I DON'T SEE MYSELF AS A HERO,
I SEE MYSELF AS DOING WHAT
NEEDED TO BE DONE TO TAKE OUT
THE EVIL THREAT AND AT THAT
POINT I DIDN'T HAVE A CLEAR SHOT
BECAUSE PEOPLE WERE STANDING UP
AND FINALLY ABOUT A SECOND LATER
I HAD A CLEAR SHOT AND I TOOK
THE SHOT AND THE SHOOTER WENT
DOWN.
SINCE WHEN DO YOU KNOW WHEN
SOMETHING BAD IS GOING TO HAPPE
HAPPEN?
YOU HAVE TO BE PREPARED AT ALL
TIMES AND ALL PLACES.
AND THAT IS THE WAY THAT I
STRIVE IN THE WAY THAT I TEACH.
>> MARIE, I WILL GO TO YOU.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
REPUBLICANS SAY ALL THE TIME, A
GOOD GUY WITH A GUN CAN STOP A
BAD GUY WITH A GUN AND BECAUSE
OF THE LAWS WITH THE TEXAS
LEGISLATORS PASSED IN MY HOME
STATE OF TEXAS, PEOPLE ARE
ALLOWED TO CARRY IN CHURCH, BUT
NOW THEY ARE ABLE TO ORGANIZE
CHURCH GROUPS THAT ARE
VOLUNTEERS TO STOP BY GUYS LIKE
US.
WHAT SAY YOU?
>> Marie: IN THIS SITUATION
OBVIOUSLY THIS MAN WHO STOPPED
PEOPLE FROM SHOOTING MORE PEOPLE
AS A HERO.
IT'S A GOOD THING THAT HE WAS
THERE, HE WAS ARMED AND HE WAS
ABLE TO DO THIS.
I FOR ONE DON'T WANT MY CHURCH
TO TURN INTO A SHOOT-OUT, I
DON'T WANT MY PLACE OF WORSHIP
TO TURN INTO A SHOOT-OUT AND
THIS IS NOT A SOLUTION LONG TERM
FOR THE GUN VIOLENCE PROBLEM WE
HAVE IN THIS COUNTRY.
I DON'T THINK WE SHOULD LET THIS
ONE STORY WHICH IS AN AMAZING
STORY, WE SHOULD POINT OUT, LET
US TAKE OUR EYE OFF OF THE BALL
IN TERMS OF WHAT ARE SOME COMMON
SENSE SOLUTIONS WE SHOULD HAVE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
UNIVERSAL BACKGROUND CHECKS
INCLUDING GUN SAILS, NOT SAY WE
ALWAYS NEED TO HAVE A CIVILIAN
ARMED.
BY THE WAY, THAT DOESN'T ALWAYS
END THE WAY IT DOES HERE, IT CAN
BE QUITE DANGEROUS WHEN YOU HAVE
A LOT OF PEOPLE WITH GUNS TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT WHO IS THE
ASSAILANT AND WHO ISN'T, THIS
SHOULD NOT LET US STAND IN THE
WAY OF DOING ACTUAL COMMON SENSE
GUN REFORMS DESPITE THE FACT
THAT IT'S AN AMAZING STORY.
>> EMILY, WHILE CONGRESS IS
TRYING TO FIGURE IT ALL OUT,
PEOPLE WANT TO FEEL PROTECTED
AND THERE'S NOT ENOUGH COPS TO
PROTECT US ALL.
SO SHOULDN'T WE BE ASKING FOR
MORE LIVES LIKE THIS SO PEOPLE
FEEL PROTECTED?
>> Emily: TO ADD TO THAT
REMARKABLE QUALITY ABOUT THE
SITUATION, THAT LAW JUST PASSED
IN SEPTEMBER AND IT'S JUST A
COUPLE MONTHS OLD, THAT ENABLED
PARISHIONERS TO HAVE THEIR CARRY
CONCEALED INSIDE AND ALSO THE
SECURITY FORCE THAT THEY
CREATED.
I THINK THE STATE SENATOR WHO
COSPONSORED THE BILL SAID IT
BEST WHICH IS THAT THERE IS NO
SUCH THING AS A GUN FREE ZONE.
SHE SAID EVIL PEOPLE WITH EVIL
INTENTIONS WILL CARRY OUT THEIR
HEINOUS ACTS REGARDLESS OF THE
LEGISLATION THAT'S IN PLACE WERE
NOT IN PLACE.
SO IN THE INTERIM I BELIEVE
THOSE LAWS THAT ENABLE
LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS TO CARRY
AND CONCEAL TO FEEL PROTECTED,
THAT'S WHY WE CAN PROTECT
ANOTHER SITUATION LIKE THIS
WHERE WE CAN IF IT COMES TO ADD,
RECREATE IT.
AND SIX SECONDS, THAT COMING WAS
TOLD TO COME A FINAL .2.
THEY HAD BEEN TRAINING FOR THIS.
AS THE PARISHIONERS STATED, THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO HAVE IT COME TO
FRUITION BUT IT'S ALSO SOMETHING
THAT LAW-ABIDING CITIZENS CAN
PULL OUT OF THEIR SLEEVE.
>> I SHOULD NOTE THAT THIS IS A
VOLUNTEER FORCE AND IF MANY OF
YOU HAVE SEEN THE VIDEO, THEY
ALL SPRING INTO ACTION.
YOU CAN CLEARLY SEE THAT THEY
HAVE TRAINING, BUT TOM, WHAT DO
YOU THINK ABOUT PEOPLE TAKING
THE DESTINY INTO THEIR OWN
HANDS?
THERE WERE
THIS WAS A VOLUNTEER FORCE, THEY
JUST DECIDED THEY WANTED TO GO
TO CHURCH AND PROTECT THEMSELVE
THEMSELVES.
>> THEY ALWAYS SAY THEY ARE NOT
A HERO, AND, FIRST RESPONDERS,
AND I UNDERSTAND THE IRONY OF
THAT BECAUSE THEY GET THE
TOURNIQUET'S AND, PEOPLE WHO
HAVE BEEN INJURED, THEY ARE
KEEPING THEM ALIVE.
THAT'S A FIRST RESPONDER, THERE
WAS LESS CARNAGE THERE FOR THEM
TO HAVE TO TAKE CARE OF.
THE OTHER THING I LOVE, AND THEY
HAD THE SHOOTER UP THERE, I
HAVEN'T SEEN THE SHOOTER, I'M
SURE WE WILL SEE HIM, AND THEY
WOULD RATHER SEE THIS GUY THAN
THE SHOOTER ON TV.
>> TYPICALLY WE TALK ABOUT THE
POLITICS CONCERNING THE GUNS AND
ALL THIS BUT THE SIMPLE FACT
HERE IS, THERE WASN'T A MASS
SHOOTING.
IT COULD HAVE BEEN A LOT WORSE.
THESE PEOPLE SPRANG INTO ACTIONS
OF DOCTORS LIKE YOU WOULDN'T
HAVE TO HAVE A MASS CRIME SCENE
OR LIVE IN THE HOSPITAL.
>> I GOT PRETTY NERVOUS RIGHT
THERE, SORRY.
SO WE ARE ALREADY SEEING A
POLARIZED REACTION TO ANY SORT
OF SHOOTING THAT WE SEE AND I
GET CONCERNED AS TO WHAT'S GOING
TO COME THE NEXT SEVERAL DAYS IN
THE MEDIA.
WE DON'T KNOW ENOUGH ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC SHOOTING AS OF RIGHT
NOW TO KNOW EXACTLY WHAT
HAPPENED, BUT THE SMALL THINGS
THAT WE HAVE SEEN I WOULD GET
CONCERN ON MANY LEVELS BECAUSE
YOU HAVE EVERY DEMOCRAT STILL IN
THE RACE, POTENTIALLY COULD NOT
HAVE STOP THIS FROM HAPPENING.
THAT WAS ILLEGALLY OBTAINED
FIREARMS AND PROTECTING THE
CITIZENS THERE.
THIS GENTLEMAN WHO TOOK OUT THE
ATTACK, HE WAS ARRESTED IN 2016
IN NEW JERSEY FOR ILLEGAL
POSSESSION OF FIREARMS.
AND HE WAS ARRESTED WITH A
SHOTGUN IN 2016, AND HE'S
LABELED AS A TRANSIENT
SUBTLETIES BACKGROUND CHECKS
CHECKS WOULD HAVE FAILED BECAUSE
PROBABLY HAVE THESE LEGALLY AT
THIS POINT.
HE WANTED 75% OF PLAYER ARMS,
WHETHER THEY ARE STOLEN OR NOT.
THAT'S BETTER PROSECUTION, AND
THAT'S DURING A HANUKKAH
CELEBRATION IN NEW YORK CITY.
THE FBI REVEALING TODAY THAT,
MIRRORED BILL de BLASIO
REACTED BY BLAMING THE PRESIDEN
PRESIDENT.
>> AN ATMOSPHERE OF HATE HAS
BEEN DEVELOPING IN THE COUNTRY
OVER THE LAST FEW YEARS.
>> WE NEED A DIFFERENT TONE
STARTING IN WASHINGTON.
>> MARIE?
>> THIS GUY IS A CLEAR BLACK
SUPREMACIST HATEFUL PERSON,
CRAZY, AND PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
RESPONSIBLE?
>> THE FIRST IS NOT THE ISOLATED
INCIDENT UNFORTUNATELY.
AND ALSO, OTHER PARTS OF THE
COUNTRY.
I WILL SAY THAT A LOT OF HIS
RHETORIC AND HIM RE-TWEETING
RIGHTS OF PREMISES, ENCOURAGING
CONSPIRACY THEORIES AND
SUPPORTING PEOPLE LIKE DAVID
DUKE, THIS ALLOWS SOME PEOPLE
WHO, ITS EYES SOMATIC FEELINGS,
REVEALING RACIST FEELINGS, AND
IT DOESN'T MEAN IT'S HIS FAULT.
>> IS A PRESIDENT ANYWHERE
AROUND THIS?
>> I THINK THAT OVERSIMPLIFIES
THE ISSUE.
AND THEN THERE IS THE RISE IN
ANTI-SEMITIC'S, LAW ENFORCEMENT
FOR SECURITY CAMERAS ET CETERA
AND WE'VE BEEN IGNORED AT EVERY
LEVEL AND NOW WE HAVE THE MAYOR
AND THE GOVERNOR SAYING THAT
SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE DONE.
MEANWHILE THE SAME GENTLEMEN ARE
NOW REFORMING BAIL SO THAT 400
PLUS CRIME DIVISIONS OR
DIVISIONS OF CRIME HAVE THOSE
DEFENDERS RELEASED ON NO CASH OR
NO BOND AVAILABLE.
THAT'S 90% OF CRIMINAL CASES
INCLUDING ONE OF THOSE WOMEN WHO
COMMITTED THOSE CRIMES AND
PUNCHED TWO JEWISH PEOPLE IN THE
FACE MULTIPLE TIMES.
THIS IS ABSOLUTELY A HUGE PART
OF THE PROBLEM AND A QUICK
DISTINCTION FROM NEW JERSEY,
THEY CAN TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
PUBLIC SAFETY.
FOR EXAMPLE THIS WOMAN WHO
COMMITTED THAT ANTI-SEMITIC
CRIME IN THIS STATE, NO HOLDS
BARRED.
>> THAT'S -- IT'S A PRESIDENT
RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS?
>> AND STEVE CUOMO IS AN IDIOT
AS WELL FOR SAYING THIS.
IF ANYONE SAID BARACK OBAMA, HE
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR THIS, IT'S A
RIDICULOUS BUT THEY CONTINUE TO
GET AWAY WITH IT.
THIS PERSON WHO COMMITTED THESE
CRIMES IS A KNOWN SCHIZOPHRENIC.
BILL de BLASIO WAS GIVEN
$1 MILLION FOR HIS CAMPAIGN, AND
THE REST WAS A BIG P.R.
CAMPAIGN.
YOU HAVE TO FOCUS ON MENTAL
ILLNESS.
ANTI-SEMITISM IS RAMPANT, NOT
JUST THE UNITED STATES, AND